what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday september the 15th a
beautiful day to be alive from the heart
of new jersey the joint is brought to
you by draft [__] kings the
best
week one may be over but the season is
just getting started
getting in on the action at draftking
sportsbook app is the official sports
betting partner of the nfl it doesn't
get better than that that's as good as
it gets draftkings is the real [__]
deal and they're giving new customers
200 and free bets instantly for week two
just bet a dollar on any football game
did you hear what i'm saying to you bet
one dollar on any football game
and we're gonna give you 200 and free
bets instantly whether you win or lose
if you can't bet in the sports book in
your state don't worry draftkings has
huge cash prizes up for grabs all season
on their daily seat on their daily
fantasy contest listen their fantasy is
no [__] joke download the app right
now for the daily fantasy contest you're
not gonna be sorry they also have a
[__] casino that'll make [__] your
[__] pucker up draftkings is giving
all new customers a free shot of a
million dollars in total prizes with
their first deposit whether you go on
draftkings sportsbook app or you go on
the draftkings fantasy app uncle joey's
coming through on both of them if you go
on the draftkings sportsbook app it's
easy use promo code joey receive 203
bets when you place a dollar on any
football game this weekend that's promo
code joey to get your 200 honey football
game this weekend only at draftkings
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the nfl got to be 21 or older
new jersey indiana pennsylvania colorado
only bookmaking states apply new
customers only restrictions do apply see
draftkings.com sportsbook for details
now
you're not going to have a gaming pond
because you have to pay before you lay
the bet down with
draftkings that's what i love about them
but if you have a gambling problem call
1-800 gambler or 1-809 with it if you're
in indiana but if everything is straight
if all engines are set to [__] go
get let's [__] download the
sportsbook app today right now because
you're gonna [__] light your [__]
bookie on friday [__] that punk ass
[__] when you got draftking sportsbook
app and we're gonna throw 200 your way
when you bet a dollar use code joey to
get this party started the joint would
also love to welcome
md to the joint a news uh sponsor to the
no joint i love these guys they call the
md hearing aid listen to me i know
you're [__] all young
but you got parents you got uncles you
got grandpas and i'll tell you what
my hearing aid saved my [__] life a
few years back i would go to a
restaurant and if you were talking to me
i couldn't hear you all i could say is
huh can you understand what the wages
are saying or is she [__] mumbling
then md hearing aid is for you if you're
having a hard time putting all the
sounds together if you're worried about
looking like an old man don't worry
about it they have a sleek design and it
fits inside your ear so nobody knows
you're even wearing it the first time i
saw one was when i worked with ray leota
on the sopranos and i asked him and he
told me he wasn't deaf it said his his
ear wasn't capturing all the sound
that's the same problem i had so do
yourself a favor if you don't need a
hearing aid that's fine but if you do md
hearing aid is the one for you they're
water resistant you can wear it in the
shower no problem and they got a
rechargeable battery that lasts up to 30
hours listen nobody's wife talks that
much
now hearing aids can cost [__] i mean
my original ones cost 2800 a piece it's
5 200
you ready for what md hearing aid could
do for you
these are 299 each
how they simplify the design and cut out
the middleman the best part is this is
all direct to you no doctors and no
prescription needed
listen up they got six hundred thousand
satisfied customers plus you get a 45
day risk trial
and a hundred percent money back
guarantee so you have nothing
to lose listen to your uncle joey these
are as good as premium hearing aids
reclaim your life from hearing loss go
to
mdhearingaid.com again
mdhearingaid.com
use promo code joey and they're going to
get you the deal of a lifetime you ready
buy one
get one deal they're normally 600 each
but now you get the pair for 299 with
code joey if that's not a deal i don't
know what is plus they're gonna throw in
the extra charging case it's on dollar
value but just for the listeners of the
joint so head to
mdhearingaid.com and press and joey you
got questions you want to talk to them
you can even call them at 1
three three seven seven three
thirteen fifty five that's one eight
three three
seven seven three thirteen fifty five
listen up it's the md hearing aid [__]
suckers you don't have to look at me
with that stupid look on your face no
more and
the joint is also brought to you by
upstart you hate looking at your credit
card statements every month yeah so do i
when you're in debt it feels like it
never ends but upstart could [__]
help you okay upstart is fast and easy
to get a personal loan to pay off your
debt listen being in debt is not fun
right now between the moratorium
work people are having a hard time
whether it's paying off your credit
cards or consolidating your debt get a
simple fixed monthly income just a five
minute online rate check you get
approved the same day and receive funds
as fast as one business day if that has
taken over your life it's time to get a
fresh start with upstart so do me a
favor today
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
joey that's upstart.com
joey don't forget to use the url to let
them know i sent you i gotta throw this
in disclaimer loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application
go to upstart.com
joey and get out of debt today and now
it's time
to start the show we got a great great a
great guest today and we're gonna rock
your [__] world
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
welcome to uncle joey's joint it's
wednesday the 15th what'd i tell you
didn't i tell you this month was gonna
[__] move at the speed of [__]
light speed of light it's the 15th
already two days ago was the [__]
first
do the [__] math
this thing is flying jack and it's gonna
fly straight to the end of the [__]
month it's been a great week so far
had a couple things going on went to
acupuncture this week worked out
i don't i'm still waiting to hear on the
rick rubin thing for thursday i'm
excited about that
a lot of good things going on man
[__] acupuncture is great
i uh you know i went for all those that
whole time and that whole last year i
didn't go so
hopefully this will be the final [__]
step
in my recovery to feeling a lot better
you could tell i'm feeling better i'm
looking better i'm alive and kicking
like i said in the top of the [__]
show football is back
i had a great weekend this weekend
[__]
the the fair at the park the [__]
jimmy florentines was great we watched
the miami dolphin new england game and
it's so weird how much life has changed
you know i still remember eight nine
years ago
goofing on lee
because uh
he was i'm home watching a new england
game what the [__] you you play for new
england i used to bust his balls
and this week i'm sitting there watching
new england against miami and i'm
thinking to myself [__] i'm having a
good time
i go that's how [__] up i was in la
that i wouldn't even i wouldn't even
watch football like i wouldn't even
watch football everything was
on work mode and my whole life was work
mode you're not allowed to watch
football it's bad for you
things have [__] changed i'm loving
football i watched the miami game i
didn't bet any of the early games
i bet [__] the rams because i know
the rams so they came through for me and
then monday night i had a bag of [__]
because i bet the [__] raiders and i
thought it was home team underdog on a
monday night they're getting four and
everything was set up for it they were
17 24. it was 24-17 they were ready to
score and then they [__] up and that
was the end of that i had a parlay too
even though paul lays the suckers bet i
just wanted to watch the game so i threw
in a 25-hour parlay i think i would have
won like 120 or something like that it
was just something to watch the [__]
game i figured at least i have one side
that one both my sides crapped out so
i'm ready for [__] next sunday you
know i might blast some [__] college
gym but i don't know much about college
sports you gotta stay on top of that
[__] and know it
i don't know [__] about college football
so i'll just stick with pro
obviously i don't know much about pro
because i took a beating on monday
[__] night so you know you take your
[__] chances i love it i love just
putting 25 i don't have to watch the
whole game i didn't watch the whole
[__] four quarters i can't watch four
quarters i'll come down here i'll watch
the beginning after half time i watch a
few minutes then i go outside i smoke my
nightly number then i come back in i
watch the rest of the [__] game i may
play a little [__] guitar
and that's it that's my [__] night
you know i i just can't sit there and
watch [__]
18 games in a day i could sit there for
a little while take a ride that's why i
did sunday i went to jimmy's
watched a few quarters got up met my
family
went over to the [__] fair let me
tell you something it was great there
was a
ton of people there it was a co-video
event that's why i sat under a [__]
tree by myself and looked from a yonder
you know what i'm saying like i looked
from a panda whatever the [__] they call
it
i looked over it was it was it was
[__] great let me tell you something
they had these milkshakes
i didn't get one i got one for my
daughter right because i got one for a
bunch of the people yeah because we have
like six kids with us they had [__]
milkshakes with a donut on top
and you put the straw through the hole
or the milkshake
of the donut and then you bite around
the [__] donut and you
so i bought two s'mores
two reese's pieces and two oreos because
i had like
dylan gavin
mercy
nicole
and then we had the parents so i said
the four kids get shakes and then the
parents could split
two or whatever they were 10 bucks a
piece these [__] shakes there wasn't
a lot of milkshake but the donut was
[__] huge and grandioso my wife
tasted the donut she said the donut was
[__] tremendous i don't i didn't want
no donut i'm this close on the glucose
[__] level i don't want diabetes
listen if i got diabetes i'll die
because i'm not stabbing myself with no
[__] needle
the first
acupuncture
nah both of them have been good i could
lie to you and tell you i thought i was
gonna faint but nah they've both been
pretty good the first day i was a little
scared every time she touched me i
jumped a little bit because i haven't
had nobody touch me with the [__]
needles and [__] coconuts really [__]
things up for people we stopped getting
touched
like people you know like i was going to
like i wasn't going to like
massage envy or nothing those places
suck i had this chinese chick in [__]
north hollywood i used to take lee there
i used to take my wife there they would
rub your feet
your [__] calves the the front
she would give you a full body massage
for 40 bucks and this [__] was no
slouch she would elbow you to death she
would get up on the table and step on
your [__] neck there was times i
couldn't breathe
but you know what i don't live there no
more so that went away i miss her though
she used to have the afternoon happy
hour 20 bucks they do your neck your
feet and your calves they massage your
fingers your arms your hands tremendous
you go take a little edible i would go
home and wash my balls and go in there
listen to them talk chinese and [__]
when you because when you're face down
and people are talking chinese you're
like what the [__] going on i can't
see who's talking you just hear a bunch
of people yelling it's like the
beginning of janet jackson's if you ever
see janet jackson's if they got the
chinese guy
you don't know what the [__] going on
same [__] thing
when you get a massage and your head's
down the pillow you know what the [__]
is going on i don't know if i'm watering
ribs or they're gonna rub my feet i
don't know what the [__] going on
but uh yeah the fair was great you know
it's just been great let me tell you
something man it's tough to go through
life when you're [__] struggling
mentally
and
from like i think i struggled mentally
after my mother died
i think i struggled a little mentally
after i got divorced you know because
that's what i compared
what i was going through this time till
after i got divorced i felt empty like i
think the move had a lot to do with that
meeting new people
you know but the therapy took care of it
me writing took care of me
getting out there and meeting new people
took care of it and i feel great about
it guys this is what you're supposed to
[__] do i'm 58 you know what i'm
saying i i love what's going on right
now with my life
you know i miss comedy but i don't you
know i really don't i'm enjoying what i
got going on on the block and in my life
and what i'm trying to do
i'm a new [__] strength program i'm
going to get a little stronger i
included
[__] pull-ups in my routine now and
i'm including [__] squats so now i'm
gonna lift three days a week and
focusing on
one major lift all three days like
monday's a deadlift
i'm doing up to 200 [__] pounds i'm
getting [__] stronger and stronger
now for reps
you know this is what my life is about
now this is what you do you [__]
evolve and you move the [__] forward you
know this is what it's all about you
know
and
as of today we got what 15 more days
left
for the many [__] saints in
newark you can't beat that that's
you know we're halfway [__] there so
it's all good man it's all gravy and
like i told you guys i promised you
the whole month of october i would have
different
people different themes of soprano thing
i came through for you again today i
gotta be honest with you
i've done 10 years of interviews and
this is the first time
an interview made me cry
my guest made me [__] cry for once
for years i put away [__] what's his
name with the edibles and
sarah tiana and owen benjamin went down
that she didn't give me an edible she
[__] just broke me down and uh
it was great to have her on the podcast
i hope you enjoy it
uh catherine narducci from uh
bronx tale
the sopranos a bunch of other [__] she
was in the irishman she was great the
irishman she's got a great story and as
far as dysfunction go her and i are tied
for childhood dysfunction but she's
[__] great
enjoy her miss catherine narducci
[Music]
what's up beautiful
hi
i love the blonde hair
thank you
i got a blonde for we're not recording
are we
yeah we're recording we're running oh
this is live we're live we're on
memories i almost said why i got a
blonde i got a blonde for a job a great
probably one of my
all-time favorite
jobs it's it's a crazy character like
out of her mind and
the hair is i have extensions so it's
going to be long long on the show it's
long blonde but i left it
because i figured five hours in the
chair to get black to blonde why am i
gonna go throw you know black dye on my
i just left it no leave it
until you shoot and then let it grow out
[__] it
right unless somebody else says anything
how are you today my love
i'm good you know you're one of those
people that i feel like i know you yes
you too
i feel like i just know you like i know
you
and we never met no
and i'm look i was looking at this the
other day after i spoke to you
the pleasant avenue connection you ever
read this book
oh my god yes of course this is a great
book it got optioned and never got shot
but this is a great book it's look at it
my father's in that nikki no douchey
yeah i'll read it now
look i still have a mark in here from i
was on page 142 at one time
this book if you go online it costs like
500 bucks
yes and you know there's another one
that's out of print too uh
uh i've got the name about harlem it's
out of print and actually my my my
friend got it for me for my birthday
i don't know what the hell i did with
this book it's driving me crazy i
freaking lost it and i can't think of
the name of this book another one
um
i wonder if that's the one did you see
nikki not douchey in that
no i you know i read it years ago
years ago like i was hunting it down
and i even went because the only way you
could get it from a library is by going
into the library and reading it you
can't take it home
oh wow i told a friend of mine about it
he won a contest he won 250 000
and that was his gift to me he bought me
the book it was like 600 bucks the
[__]
cover was ripped
off wow
unbelievable i'll tell you one thing i
couldn't ask for a better childhood
growing up in that neighborhood that's a
great neighborhood i loved it up there i
loved everything about
everything
i'm telling you it was so beautiful and
you know i go to brooklyn now and i go
around i go wow this must have been like
back in the 70s this must have been
unbelievable
but
you always think where you grow up is
like the best but i don't know to me i
felt like i grew up in a very magical
place i felt harlem
was magical because as kids you know in
the other boroughs of great all five
boroughs of great even staten island
they're great but
everybody wants to be in manhattan i
just felt blessed as a kid
i knew at a very young age like at five
years old i used to look at my out my
window on first avenue i grew up between
on 14 and 115 and when you're from
harlem real hauling people say a honey
they don't say a hundred i go between
114 and 115
and i would look out my window i had to
be five years old and go
i love it here i'm so lucky i just know
it
i love the streets of harlem
i had an aunt that sold drugs
on 113th
right by the mouth of spanish harlem
right by the park right there jefferson
park
yes and uh
i used to go up there just to visit her
because it was like a zoo walking up the
stairs people be shooting heroin and
[__] oh yeah and they'd be nodding so
i'd go to the bodega get some a couple
empanadas or whatever the [__] they had
some coquitos and [__] yeah those little
coconut balls
the coochie free thousand i go upstairs
and see her and see the junkies
she'd give me 20 bucks and i'd walk
around harlem as a kid
very very very colorful neighborhood
very colorful that's the one thing very
cultural
just amazing just amazing the [__] there
was stuff in harlem you couldn't get in
any of the other five boroughs
yeah like little snacks and [__] every
barrow had this now i'm really proud
to be from this area like
i remember last week during the 9 11
things
how much i hurt during 9 11 because i
was in california
and i'm seeing my city getting [__]
shot down by [__] planes
i couldn't tell you how bad i felt
and people don't understand yeah i grew
up in jersey and i love jersey and it's
my heart
but my original art when i came from
cuba was that [__] manhattan
i loved it i loved everything about new
york city man everything
and then they showed me harlem and
that's where the [__] flavor of that
city is
the city is the city and you know what
that's why i'm so proud to be on the
golf course of holland i swear i did the
scout i helped them do some scout
locations and i walked them around
before we even started it and and and
before we would they were just in
getting in production and i showed them
i took them to all the clubs i took them
to where all the you know colorful
people stayed
you know what i mean in that
world
um
and
i
i was so happy to do it i've never been
so
uh
proud of the show i'm just so happy
harlem's getting it's due i'm just i
just haven't i give a uh
uh chris brancato and mark juan
um all the people who brought in jim
atchison who brought it to the table i'm
i'm just so give them a lot of props for
that man just really a lot of props for
it the godfather harlem is just
unbelievable i've heard great things
about it so i'm really happy for you
i've heard great things about it
and now that i'm living here i would
love to shoot all those [__] shows
that one the one about brooklyn with the
italians there's a ton of shows this
year you are so perfect for the
godfather of harlem it's ridiculous
yeah perfect
i was thinking about you this morning
when i was doing my gratification
because we had a long talk about that
last week yes
about
it's a different world
and
you don't know what's being said to you
anymore
i feel that everybody's [__] lying to
us everybody you know my wife ordered
food yesterday they told to be here in
20 minutes i go terry you know they're
not going to have it ready in 20 minutes
she goes no but the guy told me she got
back an hour and a half later
i said i told you everybody's lying to
you the airlines the doctors
the [__]
the who
the [__] governors nobody's being
straight with us so we have to be
straight for ourselves
so in other words this could make us
[__] go crazy this could make you go
crazy so you have to get your own corner
see what works for you what information
you have
and you have to be different in what's
going on in the world today look my
daughter's home that's why i didn't call
you yesterday
she went into school at 8 30 at 9 30
they called a kid in the class
he had contact with somebody who had
covert over the weekend my daughter
can't go back to school till next
[__] monday
i had to bring her home yesterday give
her a test and babysit all day today
she's on the computer on zoom and
until three and we're good but that
that's the world today they're not going
to go to they're going to go to school
this school's going to be closed they've
had 21 cases in three days of school
21 [__] so you have to
you know you sit there and you go i've
had enough you order a tv
they send you the wrong tv or they don't
send it to you at all it's back ordered
you get a plane ticket everything's
[__] upside down so
you need your mental [__] side so
we've been talking about it and you know
catherine said something to me about it
how you wake up in the morning you get
your cup of coffee you find a dark
corner even if it's for one [__]
minute and you think about
you know what you're grateful for really
like really dig deep like i don't give a
[__] i'm grateful for my heart i'm
grateful for this napkin and then when
you get in the shower you repeat it out
loud that's the system i do
and i [__] love it it's been it's
helped me dramatically
the last 120 days
could i tell you something i i i watched
your podcast
a lot of them in a row as i do
everything that i do like if i get on a
tv show i start watching the episodes
and i just did my research with you and
i came across that
one podcast in particular and it hit me
oh you hear all this self-help things
and things to do i don't know that one
thing in particular
it helped me even though i'm the most i
walk around going thank you god thank
you guys for everything for a glass of
water i'm like always appreciating and
very
self-aware i'm very extremely hyper
too hyper self-aware and appreciate
everything right
you said
that let me tell them what you're
talking about for people maybe that are
just tuning in don't know he said
every day you wake up and you say three
things out loud that you appreciate
is that correct yes
you say it
and i woke up the next day
and for some reason
i said oh let me try it
and i said it
and then i said i said the three things
three times
and every time i said it
it got stronger and it resonated with me
myself even though i know it and i'm the
one who's saying it i'm like
yeah
yeah i feel that you know and
when you when you appreciate even less
than oh i even appreciate you know
my apartment i appreciate i you know
when you start going down to the little
little littlest things like i appreciate
that i could [__] pay my electric
bill
you just realize
like you're saying it
we are so blessed and we don't even look
at the little things anymore
and now we have the time and the
realization to do that again because of
the way the world is so we got to go
back to our own selves and say wait
check in on you what the [__] is going
on with you and this is what's going on
and i'm like just so appreciative but i
want to just say another thing too
that helped me and i did it today
i didn't do it when i woke up i did it
when i was going for my morning coffee i
was walking and i said it out loud and
it helped me
but
you know
your charm
and
your
the reason you are where you are right
now
brutal honesty
and
especially publicly publicly it's it's
it's different than you're brutally
honest with somebody and you know just
you and this person in a private
conversation when you're brutally honest
and you're being brutally honest about
your past because i listen to you and
things you went through
crazy right
the brutal honesty
and your past
and then
overcoming all these obstacles that you
came and being brutally honest about it
is your
uh
charisma that's very charismatic to me
brutal honesty is a charismatic like to
me like a charismatic quality it all
goes with because
sometimes people don't you you'll need
to be way too much to people like oh now
this
or
which i think why you are where you are
is that
even my god son alessandro was like i
love him he says it like it is oh my god
i'm so happy you're going on a show i
love them i love my love and me and my
brothers love them and they're all
like under 25 they're kids
you're resonating with that right and
you just said something at the beginning
we're being bullshitted by everybody
right so when somebody comes along and
they're honest like you
it's so refreshing and not only that
that you overcame
such a hard life and craziness crazy
[__] dysfunctional to the highest to
the [__] if there was a scale one to
ten yours is a hundred the obstacles
that you overcame and that you're
successful and that you're here
that's why everybody loves you you give
people hope you really do i'm not even
saying i'm saying you give people hope
and you tell people
i don't give a [__] where you're from i
don't give [__] if your mother and
father were junkies you fought you had
no father i don't give a [__] if you rob
banks in the past right now today you
could change all that
and you there is hope you could always
time to change number one
and anybody if they have a
they have to want it
has a dream
no matter where you are in your life and
no matter what past you have
you can overcome that and become
somebody you can be successful and you
you are the epitome of that
you're the epitome you could come from
nothing and
and
make something of yourself you know and
i i just think that you're great i think
that
that's why your show is success
successful that's why you are successful
it's all it's the brutal honesty it's
the brutal brutal honesty and where you
come from
you know what you've come from and that
you share that with people and then you
laugh about it
and you turn that
negative into a positive that's all
that's all you have to do you know turn
that
remember that song i always made me so
happy you have to accent
an enemy
then
the negative turn it into a positive and
that's the way the story goes it's
[__] true
right you can't play the victim you know
that you gotta like you you you cannot
play the victim you have to turn that
[__] around you're responsible for
everything in your life remember the
last time you spoke to a victim how hard
was it on you
people who just do not
it's very hard on people they blame the
world they blame the world everybody but
themselves it drives me crazy
because you come from the bottom of the
[__] barrel and you didn't play a
victim you don't play a victim you you
you you overcome that you realize once
everybody realizes that everything you
do in your life
is
your [__] responsibility
you make it you you wake up in the
morning and you decide is it gonna be a
good day or a shitty day am i gonna
complain all day and blame my mother my
father my circumstances or am i gonna
say [__] this on my own person i have to
be responsible for everything that
happens to me my happiness my work my
job
what i do who i date if i'm in a bad
relationship with a guy i can't blame
the guy oh he did this to me oh he did
that's me no you did this to you by
being there and showing up with that
person
everything is when we when you get that
power it's so powerful it's a [__]
revelation when you realize you are
responsible for everything you cannot
blame anybody
if life becomes a lot easier a lot
easier and you get a lot more power
you hit it right that [__] judge told
me that
i didn't believe him and now i even
blame the kennedy assassination on me i
did it
and i feel so much better in my life
that i took responsibility for things i
was one of those people what happened to
your job ah the [__] boss wasn't a
nice guy
it's you it's you
it's always you it's nothing to do with
anybody else it's it's your attitude
it's how you're seen so you have to
change these things to move forward
and that's exactly what i did i just
take whisper i [__] up what do you
want me to do catherine i [__] up
right i tell you what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna go to bed tonight and i'm gonna
wake up and i'm never gonna [__] up like
that again yes i promise you that i'm
never gonna and just say it and you'll
be fine but people don't wanna they
wanna ride that [__] up
you [__] up that's it who cares i went
to prison they were gonna throw me in
there for nine years i was cracked i did
the four i came out they told me you
can't be an acupuncturist you can't cut
hair you can't sell real estate you
can't do anything so what do you want me
to do collect disability that's what you
when you go to prison that's what they
make you do on the way out they tell you
you're disabled
you're never going to get a job
especially now with background checks
and [__]
so is that enough to just lay down be a
[__] lay down sally [__] no
you get up you sign your [__] shoes
and you go out there and you [__]
and then you know ice whatever you gotta
do whatever the [__] you gotta do i
would [__] i don't give a [__] i i
done it before okay here's the job i
thought you did it before i never did i
just got a lot of heart and i work hard
and i know you would like that quality
okay
we got something to work with that's
right
what was your dream growing up what was
your little dream growing up in harlem
to be an actress really
since the age of five years old i swear
to you me and my mother
my mother had a voice you cannot believe
i mean like
unbelievable and she would put on these
shows we would watch tv all the million
dollar movie thriller she would say stay
up with me watch it with me and i would
watch these movies with her and
it was like my bonding time with my
mother and my mother would then act
everything out we'd watch a star wars
born with judy garland james mason my
mother would sing all the songs that a
star was born and i wouldn't she would
say take the brush make believe it's a
microphone and introduce me and i said
ladies and gentlemen bunny not gucci and
my mother would get up and just start
singing all the songs and then she'd
take the brush and introduce me and i
would act out all the
all the characters in the movie and
it was just so much fun to me
and
as i got older i never let that dream
die and it stayed with me
and um
it just you know
that was it i was born to be an actress
i was born to be an actress that's an
actor that that's it i was born to be an
actor and
and now i'm an actor thank god i thank
god you know that
my calling and
my dream and my calling and my vocation
are all the same thing you're blessed
when you have that
how old are you when you started acting
uh 28
no sh what were you doing before that
i was working in the hunts point um
terminal market as a as a biller the
fruit and produce
they do the fish up there now
right hunch point fish mark
uh fruit and produce yeah i was up there
a few months ago that's [__] crazy at
four in the morning
oh yeah that's [__] real up there at
hunt's point
they moved it from the other fish market
that one fulton
fulton used to be in the city
and then they closed that and they now
all the fish is being sold out of hunts
point so my brother has a fish company i
went up there with him like three months
ago it's [__] crazy
i thought i was definitely gonna get
covered thank god i got the [__] out of
there
when you were a kid did you go to the
fresh head from getting off the subject
yes
you did that when i was when my mother
when we came here my mother had a dry
cleaner in the bronx she was partners
and the dry cleaner in the bronx and
they had that program for kids up there
the fresh air program where they take
you to camps and [__] like that was that
you you go live with a strange family
in harlem all the kids would leave all
at the same time every year we'd go to
look why do your house they check you
for lice they check your feet for um at
least feet
and
that was it you got a
put at five years old you got put on a
train
my mother used to be like thank god they
would get all the parents to get rid of
all the kids and all you'd get on a
train
at
grand central
you would get a i swear to you a number
around your neck on a piece of cardboard
they'd stick you with a suitcase you'd
get on a train and the number had like a
number like eight blue like the card
would be blue and it would have a number
you'd get up my mother would go okay bye
keep me on the train i'd be like ah
i end up you get off the train they say
blue eight and that's the stop you would
get off you hold your [__] card up
like this your family has the same card
and they find you when the credits go
hey you're my family you go stay with
them for two weeks you're in a complete
stranger's house
for two weeks
and you just you're just like i'm
packing your bag i could have got raped
molested it was a crazy problem i don't
know how my mother sent me but
you would go away for two weeks and you
were not allowed to call your family you
were not allowed to be in touch and ah
oh my god
i had fun and i i used to cry
and then
sometimes get abused by the kids they'd
say you know you're on welfare get out
of our house like the kids would
sometimes be mean
and
sometimes i would like it i'd get a good
family but
i didn't know if you went on i went to
that program i got i did it i think it
will miss the williams family they were
african-american
that's great they were great and it's
funny that you said they were and here's
the funny thing they lived in harlem
they lived in harlem the williams is
wait
you went to the fresh chef fund in
harlem yeah
because my godmother lived on 148th
street so all the kids would go down
125th street that little
center down there
so that was i thought that was the fresh
air fund
i'm not sure
i don't know if that's the first the
first you have fun you would go the law
you know what the slogan was
take a kid up
take a kid out of the jungle and give
them fresh air
yes
i remember that now yes
and it would be the commercial would be
a kid
um
like a kid on uh you know like when they
have the rope hanging from a tree and
you go out and you fly into the lake
like time would be it would be a kid in
the city take the kid out of the jungle
and give them fresh air be a part of the
fresh air
now where does harlem run from
technically
i think well east harlem
runs from i'm gonna say
i may be wrong i'm gonna say east harlem
runs from
first avenue
uh because pleasant doesn't go all the
way up pleasant only goes from 114 to
100 uh
second i think so
you'd go from um a hun
hundredth street i'd say like a hundred
i'd say harlem east homes that's like
from 99 to like
122nd from first avenue now i'm talking
east harlem to like
lexington avenue
so you got that little corner pocket
and uh
a very magical place
and where's regular harlem run from
so
then harlem i guess
west harlem
uh would be well that i was in consider
i i lived in el barrio they call it
right right
spanish home
um
and then
west harlem i think it's the west side
starts from what like uh
park avenue all the way down to uh
all the way down to like almost like the
west side highway that's yes it does run
to the water that's right west slalom is
than west harlem has got a lot more than
east harlem
you know west harlem was bigger as [__]
you know
area wise
so you got to remember that i lived on
88th street on the west side
but for me to get records and [__] i
would have to walk up the hall
and i still remember being six
and walking up to get james brown's hot
pants
wow
up in harlem you weren't there was no
fear
we just walked and then i would hit
harlem from both directions i loved
125th street i loved everything about it
oh yeah i loved that i remember even in
93 i used to cop weed on 125th street on
broadway there was little bodega
and then there was a weed spot three
doors down the guy we used to call the
guy mr wendell from that song that came
out in 93. i forget the name of the band
mr wendell whatever the [__]
what was your first acting job
what was your first acting job that you
wrote oh my first acting job was a bronx
tale
are you serious that was your first
first first acting job
i was i was an undercover actress my
family did not know
that i was acting because every time i
would mention it they weren't being mean
they weren't like oh you can't do it or
negative they would just like laugh or
think it was unrealistic it wasn't like
anybody was going you know
uh my mother my mother and father were
already dead so i didn't have parents
saying oh you gotta do this that anyway
even if my mother followed alive he was
very dysfunctional they wouldn't give a
[__] anyway it wasn't like go to school
or anything like that but it was more
like
you got two kids where you going you
know like that or like you got to be you
know you got to support yourself you
know
not being mean just be looking out for
me and so i was doing it on the down low
i would get backstage i would do all
these little things go on
go on uh auditions through backstage
and when i was at the hunts point town
market this woman annabella who i worked
with said you know there's an open call
it doesn't because they knew i was doing
it they said there's an open call robert
de niro's got an open call for a little
boy you should take your son and then
you can meet him we didn't know how it
worked i was like oh [__] yeah i'll take
my son for closure oh i take my son
on the open call there was an open call
for closure
and when i'm there
i see
that the women start walking in that
look like me walk like me and talk like
me and i was like [__] what are they
here for i could do whatever they're
here for when the casting director came
out with my son i said can i go in with
whatever they're going in for and she
goes the little boy's role is in open
fall today
the the wife and i didn't know the wife
was daryl's arrow's wife because the
wife is
um
not an open call but if we don't find it
today i said our actors today will open
it's an open call tomorrow call me in
the morning and i'll let you know if you
can come back
so i said oh okay
i'm getting dressed i'm ready to go to
work i said you know what let me call
i call up i said hey did you find the uh
the wife and she goes no you can come
i went back
this is a god's honest true story i went
back
and i
auditioned
and i go home
and my cousin comes with me to the
audition i tell her and she's like why i
was like just just come with me please
i'm nervous she comes with me
i do my audition the next morning i'm
getting dressed for work again
the phone rings my cousin i thought my
cousin called somebody and said call and
act like she got like they were
goofing on me
i answered the phone i'm getting dressed
for work and she goes hi this is um
ellen chenoweth you were here uh you
came in for you know blah blah blah and
i was like she goes bob wants to meet
you and i went
i hung up the phone and i said to my
cousin oh you're so [__] funny what
he just goes i didn't do anything i said
oh my god the phone rings calls she
calls back so hi just selling gentlemen
listen um
bob saw your tape you wanted to know if
you would like you to come down for for
a call back
and i was like bob who
she goes robert de niro and i was like
what what did i saw my tape
and
i went down then yes i can yes yes yes i
went down it was like
2500 girls there
and
i
i i waited a long time like three hours
i finally got in that room it was
daenerys
jane rosenthal
and the casting director i got in the
room
and you know
here's the thing
when i was down in that waiting room
and i saw all these girls there
and i said holy [__] i thought it was
just going to be like me i didn't
understand how this worked i never did
anything professional yet
and i looked around i i made my aunt i
told my aunt what i did i said please
call me i'm nervous i went down to
tribeca
and i remember i looked around and they
were getting close to me
and i looked up in the atrium and i saw
dinero look over and he waved and i went
oh my god danielle just looked over he's
up there oh my god and my ankles calm
down i said oh my god i'm so i'm i don't
want to do it i don't want to do it i'm
too nervous i'm too nervous i love it i
couldn't breathe i was past felt like i
was going to pass out
and all of a sudden i thought about my
mother
and me and my mother what we used to do
when i told you we used to do our thing
and
when my mother was alive she said please
become an actress i want you to work
with robert de niro he's my favorite
you've got to become an actress please
work with robert de niro i love him
and i
remember i
all these in the atrium like all the the
sun was coming in and all these little
you know when the sun has like sun
particles in the rays and i looked up
and i said mom
please don't make me nervous anymore
take it away from me if i go in there
i'm nervous i won't get the role i got
to be calm
please mom please stay with me
and i remember this
i'm not joking this whole warm feeling
came over me
and i just looked at my aunt and i just
like got
calmed down and they go catherine
narducci and it came right back up i was
like oh [__]
and i got started getting closer and
closer and closer and i walked in the
room and chas was there and he went hi
and i was like hi and i was like so
nervous and he goes say hi to bob and i
was like i did not want to turn my head
and see robert de niro's face i went
and i just started feeling buzzing in my
head my fingers were numb and he looked
at me go i said i'm so nervous i have to
be honest with you honestly honestly i
have to be nervous uh honest with you
i'm so nervous right now he goes you're
supposed to be nervous go sit down have
some water when you feel not nervous
just go like this
i sat down they bring me water and i
look up in those [__] sun rays in the
womb and i just look just like as i said
mom
this is real this is not a broken down
theater
i'm in the room with your guy
please please stay with me let me do
good please mom please stay with me
got that feeling again and i just went
boom
i'm ready
and
he sat down and said you ready we're
going to read some lines
and then we're going to improvise
didn't even know what the [__]
improvising then i read the lines
and he looks at me and they look at each
other like
you sure you're not an actress like you
know i said no
he said okay now we're gonna improvise
we start improvising he tells me i said
he said i'm gonna say something whatever
comes natural to you you say back we'll
do it i do that i do that
the whole time my mother is inside my
body i am just like i did it my whole
life
and i'm so calm i'm so relaxed i feel
like
i'm supposed to be here right now this
is where the [__] i am supposed to be i
am supposed to be right here
and
i
got up i was done and he goes listen
there's a slight chance we may call you
to come back
and i was like oh okay
i went downstairs i was done i went to
my aunt's goals how did i call you in
there so long
i said i think i think i did good i
think i'm gonna come back
i got home on my answering machine hi
you're gonna come back
went back i did it over and over and
over and over until the last
um i screen tested
and
i
they said we're going to call you guys
over the weekend
we're going to let everybody know who
who's in and who's not and over the
weekend they called me jazz called me
said hey rosina that's my character's
name i was like
and i got it
[__] great story
yeah that was great that was your intro
to this life
that was my intro could i tell you
something about brutal honesty and this
is the god's honest truth who's ever
listening to this
when i was in the room with the casting
director
and i wish they still have that tape
i won't say everything i said right now
but i'll say some of what i said she
said when you're done with those sides
tell me who you are
and on god i looked in the camera and i
said my name is cat and i was always
brutally honest like you and that is a
loaded question tell me who you are even
on regular nine to five job interviews
the worst question they could ask me
because that's how i didn't get the job
in that world
tell me who you are and i said my name
is catherine naducci and my whole life i
knew i was supposed to be an actress and
everywhere and every job i ever had i
would look out the window and daydream
that i was supposed to be an actress and
i wasn't supposed to be there that i was
supposed to be right here
and my father was murdered when i was 10
shot down my mother suffered from mental
uh nervous breakdowns my whole childhood
i come from a very dysfunctional
childhood my sister my dad
but i spilled out all my family dirty
laundry
and then i just went
oh my god could i do it over she went no
thank you
and i went i'm not gonna get the [__]
job i just blew the job
i knew i did a great audition but i just
blew the [__] job
and when i got that job
de niro said to me the first day of work
you know why you got this and i said why
it goes because you told the truth in
your audition
stay with that honesty stay with that
that's how you gotta act just be really
honest
that's what acting is
it's honesty that is one of the best
[__] stories i've heard in the
entertainment business and 23 [__]
that is great
that is tremendous and you took the ball
and ran from there it's never stopped
well it's always been a struggle i mean
i i'm a working class actress i mean i'm
no a lister i'm a worker you know i work
a lot sometimes i don't work sometimes i
work
but
no matter what
you know
i always say this people when they go
you know even when i taught i taught
like a couple semesters at um school
visual arts i say if you're not willing
to
just work the rest of your life
if i told you you would work the rest of
your life in a broken down theater
nobody will even see you but you can act
in that theater you can do all the plays
you can do [__]
you can do that the rest of your life
you're an actor
but that's where you'll do it will you
still want to be an actor
and if they say yes then i say then do
it because you'll never be miserable
when you're not working you'll never be
miserable when you got told no you'll
never be miserable when you don't work
for long periods of time because you're
just [__] happy
being who you are and what you were
meant to be so when i had dry spells
of course i wanted to work because i
needed to pay my bills
but i never said all this [__]
business oh [__] this [__] that i was
never not happy for my friends that
worked all the time all my friends
worked all the time
and i was always still happy for them
and i was happy for them because i said
i want to be around working actors i
don't want to be around a bunch of
non-working actors although i was around
a lot of non-working actors i like being
around working actors it teaches me and
it gives me hope
i want you to get it even if i don't get
it because then you are my inspiration
if she got it i can get it that's how i
always took it when somebody else got my
job that's not my job i got the job
that's how i look at things
is positive because i just
want to be an actor i don't want to be
famous i just want to be an actor and i
want to be able to pay my bills and i am
successful
you are
that's a great attitude to have
and you haven't stopped since i remember
after the sopranos ended i saw you at an
audition for something
to play a cop or something oh
i think it was csi new york
i think we auditioned i think so i think
it was yes
no i just said hello to you
you had on pants you were dressed like a
cop and that's the only i was i've been
thinking about it for the last couple
days
what auditions i went in that time and i
think it was csi new york
when it first came out
like the original cast like this one wow
to shoot the pilot
so it was a long time ago but you have
not [__] stopped how did you end up
getting the sopranos
kathy moriarty called me
who i love
and to me she's such a [__] great
actress man yes she is um kathy moriarty
called me she goes nah dude she named me
not dude everybody calls me not douche
no don't your kitty are my two nicknames
she goes no douche you gotta go for this
show uh the sopranos and i was like but
i don't sing
she goes no it's not about that she goes
you got to go in you're right for it
call your agent i call my agent he goes
all right i'm on it and then i got an
audition i auditioned for edie falco's
role
and they call me back
of course only edie could have done
edie's role brilliant edie who i love
um edie falco's role and then they call
me back and i went in for charmaine
bucco and uh i got called the next day
for that they said you know david wants
to give you charmaine buco so i was
blessed
again
unbelievably blessed you did great on
that show you were great [__] great
you
thank you
and now we're here you know what i'm
saying i'm sorry you're not gonna go to
the premiere
i would love to see i heard from vinnie
last night
well no you know what wait let me tell
you we were i think we're all i mean i'm
invited to the many saints of noah yes
yes
premiere but
i may have to go back to the show that
i'm blonde for
if i don't
i definitely want to comment and i and i
want to see everybody i would hope all
the sopranos gone i'd love it i'd love
to see we all love seeing each other and
i get to see you
yes no they're all supposed to go i
heard from vinnie last night
and he said he'll see me at the premiere
i heard
from a friend of is he's going so yeah
everybody's gonna be there oh and i'm so
happy
i i you understand i did the wizard of
lies with alessandra yes yes and i
me and alessandro i love him and i love
his wife and i love their family and
i just
am so happy for him i am so happy for
michael
i'm happy for david chase he's
unbelievable he don't stop
i'm i'm just i'm just really happy about
this movie i'm happy for you
i'm just it's so
everything's a win-win
yes it's a win-win i'm happy for dave
i'm really happy for michael
and i think i hate talking [__]
but i think alessandro is going to come
out with an award from this [__]
thing
or at least the nomination
yes when he got it
yes he's going to be i think this is a
good movie i think they all did well you
saw it yeah
i saw it about three months ago but i
think it's going to be different
how did you like yourself
in all honesty
yeah i looked away
why i hate looking at myself on film
you want to know could i say something
you told me about the not me you told
the whole world three me the three
things the three uh
the three things you you know are uh
appreciate and yes great grateful for
i'm gonna tell you something
when you watch yourself
and watch it again
go with a different perspective
and
love yourself and say wow self
you doing pretty [__] good from a kid
from [__] nothing look at you up
there look at you look at your eyes look
at your mouth look at your nose your
ears your hair look at your body you're
up there you're in a beautiful movie
you're so blessed look at you kid look
at you kid look how good you're doing
now and look at yourself beautifully
because all that put together
made them hire you
and and and appreciate it let that be
one of the things i appreciate me on a
screen with all these fabulous people i
appreciate me
being able to be seen and heard i
appreciate me to be doing what i love i
appreciate it i appreciate
my face my body that's what got me there
i'm healthy i see i breathe i taste
i hear i i have you know all these
things all these things that put me
together me me me
i appreciate you i appreciate you joey i
appreciate you and let your little inner
child that was beaten up and broken down
look up at that screen and say
we did it
that's [__] beautiful
that is as beautiful as it gets
we did it
we did it we [__] did it
and i don't care if it goes nowhere you
never work again you [__] did it
you [__] in a child
that tries to keep going the sparkle in
your eye the honesty you have
all the things that make you
did it
so i look at it again differently unlike
you captain right here it's all about
this right here
that's me and my mom
she died when i was 16
and this is it right here
she wanted me to grow up and be a man i
did
that's it uh what's her name danora
lenora dinora
the noira
with a d
the norah he did it we did it
we [__] did it the nora bunny my
mother was bunny and she's up there too
and nikki my father but
i don't care scrappy kids from nothing
i don't care how big or small
we're trying give yourself a [__] hug
give yourself a break give yourself a
little pat on the shoulder
appreciate the little moments because
that's your life right there right now
this moment
it's every single step we take it's our
life that's it can't keep waiting for
the big event the big this the big
apartment my biggest my most happiest
times is when i [__] had nothing you
know as a kid i was homeless a couple of
times we slept in central park on
newspapers and
very you know short period of time like
two weeks then again we did it for a
week and i gotta tell you we got evicted
i was still so [__] happy
like what the [__] is my stupid like i
just
feel you've got to appreciate your life
the good the bad the ugly it's your
[__] life and then it's over
then it's over
and right now
it's like you're here appreciate it and
you're not gonna be miss happy go lucky
or mr happy go lucky all day every day
and appreciate but
try try try
to to just appreciate it like you
looking at yourself on screen look again
man look again to that little joey diaz
[__] 10 year old that was going
through a [__] look again and go man
what the [__]
you got up there we did it
we did it
that's it it's to be appreciated
i really appreciate it now now you
really gave me a different appreciation
for it yes
i love you you made a mark in this world
you really [__] this is one of the
best podcasts i've done in a long
goddamn time
you screamed oh don't make me cry you
[__] schooled me today i love it i am
uh blown away i had tears in my eyes
you made me think about my mom you
really [__] hit it out of the park
that was great you are a [__] star
i appreciate you with all my [__]
heart you know i would watch you and go
wow
she's bringing something different to
the table and now i know what it is
you're bringing to the table you got a
lot of heart
man you got a lot of [__] heart
harlem filled your heart with [__]
balls and toughness
you're the real deal dardooch
homage to kathy moriarty
i love her too i haven't seen her in
years she still have the pizza place
you know i don't know i'm not clear i
spoke to her about uh
maybe three weeks ago
i i didn't
i forgot what she said i think i asked
her but i forgot what she said
i forgot yeah they opened up a new one
by my house before i moved
from la they had opened up a new pizza
place by my house
i'd gone to it once it was good you know
it was
their pizza good pizza and street pizza
yeah
yeah they opened one in studio city
before i left so
it was great
um
how long is your podcast are we going
too long no that's it we're done
oh okay okay we're not filming anymore
no we're filming we're going to end
right now
i love you to death i'm happy you came
on today it was tremendous they're gonna
[__] love you
let these savages know where they could
find you
do you have any social media anything
yes i just started following you coco
and that's my niece's name shout out to
coco they could find me i don't know i
guess on on uh instagram twitter
um that's it really i don't have
anything fancy i have instagram no
website
no okay
i love you not douche you should start
one of these podcasts not gucci you're
very good at this
no i like
i i i know you [__] just blew me away
today so
you're very good at this i don't get
blown away too much
you have some deep knowledge so i love
you to death
you have a new fan a bigger fan i was a
fan already now i'm a bigger [__] fan
because i got to look at your heart
and what you're about so thank you very
much for coming on today
and let's stay in touch okay
i'm going to call you every week and be
in touch with you and these guys know
i keep in touch with people i don't [__]
around when i love you i love you to
death so
i appreciate you taking the time to come
on today catherine
i i got and i appreciate you and let me
tell you you gotta get on i'm telling
chris brancato we need joey diaz on
we'll do it i love you stay black and
stay in touch with me okay
okay and thank you very very much for
today you're a beautiful woman i love
you to death
thank you well family that's it
stay in touch okay all right god bless
you have a great week
bye you too bye beautiful
what's happening you bad [__] i
hope you enjoyed catherine
it was uh a great little tata day you
know she broke it down i have a hard
time watching myself guys and i have a
hard time listening to myself because i
hate my voice
and i hate what the [__] i look like
look at look like
but
when i go to this premiere next
wednesday
i'm gonna take her advice and look at my
eyes look at my face
and pat myself on the back you know what
it's time i did that anyway i've never
done that before in my life
it's time to [__] uh smell the
[__] roses
and see what's going on i hope you
enjoyed today's podcast it's from the
bottom of my [__] heart like i do all
of them some of them are good
some of them are bad but the thing is we
always [__] show up right mike
we always [__] show up
episode 97 three more to a hundred are
you [__] kidding me
or 98 i'm you know i'm saying i'm a
little off i'm a little [__] off
but uh we're making it happen and we're
doing it i'm happy you guys checked in
today
again i have no dates to give you or
nothing like that the only thing i have
for you is laughing gas like a
[__] it came in and from what
i'm hearing it's stronger than ever
i haven't gotten my little [__] box
yet but
a friend of mine went down and he goes
dog i bought it last time
and i bought it this time and it's
[__] smoking so
uh today some kid hit me up on twitter
and said i went to [__] la and i
bought some and it's [__] tremendous
i love it joey so
it is what it is thank you and
a strain is coming out in denver and
it's coming out and [__] uh somewhere
else i was told they're all fake guys
so if somebody in denver tries to sell
you
laughing gas it's a fugazi if somebody
in san jose tries to sell you laughing
gas it's a fugazi and there's somebody
in san diego it's a fugazi i'll let you
know
when that weed is available with the
original bag so you could [__] save
it okay you know i don't [__] with you
[__] and i love you at all my
heart i don't want you buying the wrong
thing when you're looking for a joey
diaz shirt if it isn't on joeydiaz.net
it's a fugazi so just to let you know
any of these sites you see they're all
fugazis when somebody tells you they're
selling laughing gas it's a fugazi
if you check with laughing gas and
instagram
they'll tell you what stores they're at
and now we're about to put it in stores
so i'll keep you guys posted
without further ado that's it
i want to thank catherine narducci for
coming on
please follow her on instagram supporter
movies
she's [__] the real deal holyfield
and that's it and that's that another
fun-filled weekend
another fun-filled week here at [__]
the joint studios my basement who gives
a [__]
i love you [__] at all my heart
thank you for checking in on the joint
today have a great week and i'll see you
[__]
tip top [__] magoo monday the
20th
now we're in double digits in the double
digits [__] and it'll be down to
10 days for this movie to get released i
love you guys with all my heart have a
great week
thank you for supporting and now for a
word for my [__] sponsors jack
all right you bad [__] thank
you very much for taking the time and
listening today and always supporting
our [__]
dream okay i want to thank catherine
narducci for coming on today
and making me [__] cry i love it when
somebody makes me [__] cry but she
opened up my mind to a few things i hope
she opens up yours too
again thank you very much for supporting
the joint before we go i got a word from
our sponsors i'd like to welcome our new
sponsor md
hearing aid i know joey what the [__]
we're young men why are you telling us
about hearing aids because i want to
talk to you about how it improved my
life i can hear things now i hear birds
chirping i hear airplanes i hear the
clicker when i turn the left on signal
on my car you know for years i didn't
hear the clicker do you answer every
question with a huh can you understand
the waitress is mumbling then md hearing
aids are for you
if you're worried about looking like an
old man don't because they got a sleek
design
design that fits in your ear it's nearly
invisible nobody will know they're water
resistant so if you forget to take them
out no problem my other ones the good
ones the twenty ones i can't bring them
in the shower i'll get electrocuted they
got a rechargeable battery and lasts up
to 30 hours listen nobody could talk
that much
so these hearing aids can cost you up to
thousands of dollars my old ones cost 2
800 a piece
but these the vault plus from md hearing
aid
299 each
they simplify the design and they cut
out the middleman and this is all direct
to you no doctors or prescriptions
needed
so listen up they have over 600 000
satisfied customers
they give you a 45-day risk treat free
trial and 100 money-back guarantee if
you're not happy
that's what i'm talking about if you
struggle with hearing loss at all you
better try md hearing out right now
reclaim your life from hearing loss
okay go to mdhearingaid.com
use promo code joey and they're gonna
give you something that they've never
done before you buy one you get one free
deal they're normally 600 for the pair
md hearing aid is going to do them for
each for the pair with code joey and to
code joey and i'm giving you one
basically for free
plus i'm throwing in the extra charging
case that's 100 value
for free for the chur the joint family
so head to mdhearingaid.com
and preston joey you got questions
seven 1-833-773-1355 three
one three
five five
hello it's md hearing aid call them up
right now but remember
when you press in joey they're gonna
give you one for free so it's usually
600 it's gonna be 299.
thank your uncle joey and thank him the
hearing aid for that
from the heart of jersey the joint is
brought to you by draftkings the best
you're like joey
listen draftkings is the official sports
betting partner of the nfl you can't get
no better than that
week one is over at football we can't
bring that back the rams beat the bears
the whole [__] deal sandy uh you know
baltimore beat the raiders what are you
gonna do
but you gotta get on the action right
now because if you bet a dollar
they're gonna give you 200 and free bets
instantly just bet one dollar in a
football game if you can't bet
sportsbook in your state don't worry
draftkings has a huge catch prizes up
for grabs all season with the daily
fantasy contest draftkings is giving all
new customers a free shot at a million
of dollars in total prizes with their
first deposit they also have a casino
with blackjack roulette poker
draftkings is safe reliable secure you
can get your money out whenever the [__]
you want to so do yourself a favor if
you're gonna bet anyway download the
draftking sportsbook app today use promo
code joey to receive 203 bets that's
promo code joey to get 203 bets
this week at draftkings sportsbook app
the official sports betting partner the
nfl i got a couple rules for you right
you got to be 21 or older new jersey
indiana pennsylvania colorado all the
gambling states are allowed new
customers only for this deal
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gaming problem i don't want you hanging
around i don't want to bury you guys
you know take care of it call one eight
hundred gambler if you're in jersey if
you're in indiana call one eight hundred
nine with it but if you checked you
can't get in trouble with draftkings you
know why because you have to pay before
you bet so everything's covered this is
the way to go download the draftking
sportsbook app today it's time to win
some guitars better dollar to get you
back 200 come on
that's a deal in itself that's the next
four weeks at 50 a piece bet
until you get your [__] job or you
get a check or you mug somebody go to
graftingkings.com right now
preston joey
put in a dollar and get 203 bets the
joint is also brought to you by upstart
since we're talking about money listen
everybody hates looking at that credit
card statement every month when you're
in debt it feels like it never [__]
ends but guess what i'm bringing you
upstart and they can help upstart is a
fast and easy way to get a personal loan
to pay off your [__] debt listen
nobody likes being in debt it sucks and
you're never gonna get out of it you
know that you and i both know that stop
[__] around whether it's paying off
your credit cards or consolidating all
your debt get a simple fixed monthly
payment every month it's nice and easy
over a million people have used upstart
to get out of debt and you're sitting
there broke not knowing what to do
unlike other lenders upstarts looks at
more than just your credit score they
take into account your income your
employment in
history this means they can offer
smarter rates with trusted partners you
dig me just a five-minute online rate
check you get approved the same day and
you can receive the funds the next
business day that's what upstart is all
about if upstart if that is taking over
your life
it's time to get a fresh start with
upstart let's do this today all right
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
joey just go there take the five minute
quiz to see where you're at that's
upstart.com
joey
upstart.com joey do not forget to use
the url to let them know i sent you now
i gotta throw in this disclaimer loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application
go to upstart.com
joey and get out of debt today
upstart.com
joey i want to thank upstart i want to
thank md hearing aid and i want to thank
draftkings sportsbook app all three of
them
dot com slash joey win some money with
draftkings
hear what they're telling you with md
hearing aid
and get out of debt with upstart i love
you [__] i want to thank
catherine again i want to thank you guys
i want to thank
draftkings me undies
manscaped
uh
who else oh my god there's so many who
else
public wreck
you guys have been great have a great
week
stay black
and i love you [__] i'll see you
guys monday
tip top [__] magoo
[Music]
you